il n'y en avait pas
vient maintenant le joker
hier c'est pas un film qui est basé sur
des effets des gags tarte à la crème
c'est un film qui se passe sur un
comique de situation et on peut donc
jouer ça très sincèrement c'est à dire
ces deux garçons arrivent dans des
situations qui sont pour nous très drôle
et qui sont pour l'équipe aussi très
drôle puisque tout le monde se marre
quand on joue je veux dire il ya un vrai
comique de situation une comédie que je
cherchais moins jouer la mouche ange de
feu rouge fait habituellement peut-être
ça me revient si vous voulez ça me
ramène à ce que je faisais avant surtout
la d'écologie de type lundi de café
théâtre etc
sauf que là on a on a un milliard huit
pour fermeture mon nom fait sans
cinémascope confessant dolby et que tout
d'un coup ça prend des proportions
énormes
ça fait un vrai film d'action un vrai
film de tendresse et un vrai film
d'humour
c'est nouveau pour moi parce que c'est
la première fois je crois que c'est un
peu l'impression de créer un monde
complètement là quelque chose de
formidable c'est là qu'on décide de tout
depuis le démarrage d'un camion jusqu'à
la place d'un sac en passant par un
cadrage par le jeu d'un acteur comme en
plus j'ai fait les dialogues et que j'ai
que scénario avec
avec la prise de vol c'est un peu
l'impression que ça me concerne
totalement à 100% saas et quittant un
comédien qui passe à la réalisation en
même temps qui est un auteur c'est c'est
tout à fait complémentaires dire et tout
d'un coup on a affaire à quelqu'un de
très précis à change un peu des metteurs
en scène qui ne filme que leur mise en
scène et pas beaucoup dans acteurs en
général en fait vous préférez moi je
préfère
avoir quelqu'un de violent s'il vous
plaît